is forgiveness in us because i try to
forgive so much but then oftentimes i
dwell on you know
why
why they wronged me and this goes for my
brother my dad my mom
this is a good call man i appreciate it
uh thank you for calling
and um it's funny this is kind of right
where i am you know during the holiday
during easter i got to see my mother and
see my brother and
it's tough because it's like yeah how do
how long do i hold a grudge you know
and then
because at a certain point your parents
are just getting older and you're
missing out on whatever there is there
um
and yeah i think i i i believe
and it's one of the reasons why i'm
trying to recommit myself to my program
is because i believe that forgiveness is
the only
answer
i believe that
letting go of whatever that hurt is
you know sometimes i felt so hurt as a
kid i felt the
i hold on to that hurt because sometimes
it's the only relationship i had
with my mother was uh
that i was angry at her
you know and it's all i had it's all
it's the only thing that i had so it was
like so hard to let it go it's been hard
to let it go
because the only thing that i had
was my anger
or my uncomfort or my pain it was so
hard to let it go
it's like a blanket you know it's a
it's like i know this isn't good for me
but somehow it keeps me warm a little
you know the only thing i had we know
when i was young
and i'm not
talking about self-pity here or anything
like that i'm just i'm trying to really
examine this like
why we hold on to those things
um
because yeah all i all for a long time
all i had was my just my anger
and my i was wronged my that that you
know is somebody's all i had was that
and when you have that from a young age
with a parent it's
um
that's
like it's not even you holding on to it
as a conscious adult it's this [ __ ]
sh it's this inner child that's got this
claws on him you know he got them grips
the mitts baby
and so it's hard to let go of some of
that um
but i i just i just believe that the
only way to do it the only way to really
get free is to have some forgiveness you
know
and uh people do the best they can
you know i saw my mother this weekend
and uh
and all any of us are is just kids that
are just getting older you know and just
trying our best in the world
and sometimes it takes time you can't
really force it you know but
but i think we can get into practices
that help us get closer to forgiveness
and um
and that's where i want to be
because at a certain point i'm tired of
uh
of the grudges i'm
even if i'm not the one making them even
if they're from a young i've gotta talk
to myself or have a relationship enough
with my heart
that's like hey trust me enough
to walk us through this
and with my higher power
to say hey god help me get help me walk
through this
you know help me
you know i have felt unloved or i have
felt wrong or i have felt this help me
try again
to give this person a chance to love me
because if not
i miss out twice
i miss out as a child
when i didn't wasn't able to make a
choice
when i when when
when i had it was all survival instincts
that i had to to operate from
but i miss out as an adult when i am
able to make a choice
and uh
and as hard as it is i don't want to
miss out on getting to love my mother
twice
you know um
and i don't know if that makes a ton of
sense or not and
[ __ ] i don't even know if i care if it
does
uh
you know it's been for me it's been a
long journey with this kind of stuff and
and and trying to navigate it and
and that's okay
you know um
[Music]
that's okay
so
but i wish you well there brother and uh
and just know that there's other people
out there that are on this journey with
you in some ways
it could be a mother it could be a
father it could be could be a sibling
and it could be ourselves
sometimes a lot of it for me is about
forgiving
myself
you know when you are
as children you think it's your fault
you you know you take some rest but you
take so much responsibility for yourself
that if something isn't right then of
course it's on me it's on me
um
but if if stuff's on you for so long
it's on me it's on me it's on me you can
handle that for a while but i think at a
certain point you're right it's all on
you
and it's just you
and it gets kind of lonesome you know
and i'm not saying that in a self-pity
way i'm just saying that and like
you know i want my life to be filled
with other people and um
and so that's hopefully that is a
direction that i can
uh
head in you know with the help of others
and with the help of a higher power
um
you know i've been there before and uh
and i think i can be there again
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one